and for the men
um have you ever dated someone with bad
spending habits and is that something
you look for and when you're considering
taking someone seriously so let's start
on this this side of the room and go
around uh yeah I think that a lot of
what I'm hearing right now is I'm
obviously 35 years old so I've kind of
been doing the 25 year old 26 27 all the
way to the point where I was like
something's gonna [ __ ] give with this
I used to go out I used to do the cars
the clothes the this the that
um and I mean those girls that are
chasing that sort of stuff I mean it was
it was fun for the while when we were
doing it you know I mean it was those
nights was crazy you were from you see
mine out there doing that big yeah all
right cool but then when the lights come
on and you sit down with your hangover
and your pockets are empty you start
going to yourself why the [ __ ] did I do
that for like you see what I'm saying so
enough of that and then all of a sudden
you start checking yourself and
obviously for guys women can heavily
influence that like going out of your
home is just splitting bills everybody's
buying balls everybody's doing their
thing but when you have pretty girls
especially pretty girls or other guys in
the club who are flashing cash or trying
to attract as well you know it's it's
[ __ ] tiring man and I think that a
lot of people even a lot of guys who
make a lot of money will turn around and
would say that they would prefer to have
somebody that they could take that money
with and go on holiday or or buy things
for their house or there's so many other
ways and other places to spend that sort
of cast so I had to knock that one on
the head
um me and my girlfriend like to cook
more now
bottle of wine nice movie do you know
what I mean and it's cool I wake up
Saturday morning I'm like ah
I'm alive you know yeah okay what about
you the spending habit something you
look at
um when looking at a girl for a
relationship
so I was predominantly raised by my mom
so I feel like I always
I'm not sure I'm not saying it's a good
thing but I always look at my mom's
example and what she did and what she
does in terms of her example and sets
for me and I always think okay if I got
into this situation or did go into
relationship and your spending habits
were like this
would I
would I like the example you set say for
anything if we were to have children if
we were to do anything would I think Hmm
my mom would approve of you she'd say to
me oh yeah you're so lucky to have
someone that does this all would she
look at me a bit like
um what what red flags will you look for
red flags yeah
like what is there a certain lifestyle
of girls
so for in yeah like for me it'll be if
you look at the next person too much if
you see someone's wearing this kind of
design iron you want it and it's like
you follow by example you're not a
leader and that's just in terms of I
want someone that is a leader you know
what you want and it's not because
someone else is showing it it's because
you're like I'm a Visionary I'm gonna
set the example and I feel like I always
look for are you leading by example are
you being a sheep and following because
your friends see something and they're
like oh I want this this Balenciaga bag
so I want this and I'm gonna spend it on
this and then you're like you know what
rent's a bit tight this month I can't
pay it and you're like why so I feel
like I always look to the example of
would like in my head it's always with
my mom a proof of you with Mom look at
me and be like I'm so proud of what
you're doing
and the person you've chose is your life
partner because if it's not then it's
like you can't stay and obviously I feel
like people always change so it's like
you never know at the start it could
start off really good and you could be
like wow like you're so amazing you're
literally everything I imagined but then
obviously everything's a facade
sometimes when you get into a
relationship at the start it's always
people are going to present their best
selves like we can all argue you can get
into relationship and everyone's gonna
show they're a money man they're a money
girl they're about their business and
then you can get six months one year
three years into a relationship and then
they'll turn around and be like you'll
see the real them it's not even them
showing you it'll be it all begins to
fade naturally and then I feel like it's
always you kind of see everything for
yourself and I feel that it's always
important to if you see a red flag you
need to leave even if it's I'm not
saying straight away you're like oh red
flag let me jump out and run away now
it's like if it can if it happens
continuously you either bring it up or
you leave and I feel that a lot of
people in our generation they might
decide to stay and they'll look at that
red flag ignore it and then you're
always just going to be in a cycle and I
feel like that's what past Generations
have done you've seen a cycle you've
been brought up in an atmosphere where
it's always been well if you see a red
flag it's fine because you always look
at oh they bring money to the table and
I feel like we always need to in this
generation ignore red flags like not
ignore their Flags we need to
address them I feel like it's always
important to address something that is
bothering us because in past Generations
they'll tell you yeah we've been married
for 65 years and then you're like Okay
so what red flags were brought up and
you chose to ignore because I feel like
that's always an important question to
him like
[Music]
that's always an important question to
address and I feel like oh it's more
among the like the younger kind of
generation is like we will the younger
generation will start jobs quit them and
be like it's not what I want and I feel
like the oldest generation are always
the ones telling you oh we need to stick
it out we need to you need to be you can
work in like Sainsbury's and they're
like you need to stack them shelves you
need to be like one of the best then you
need to stay at the job and do this and
that and in the younger generation
you're like nah I will skip this yeah
yeah so um so what about you spending
habits have you ever um passed over a
girl for spending because she has bad
spending habits yeah I mean I mean I've
had experiences of that I'm staying away
from that never going back to that just
because I think that someone that
has a bad spending habit and relies on
you to to to support that it's like a
sinking ship do you know what I mean
what was your experience with that well
oh she just wanted you to pay for
everything no I don't mind paper I've
never gone on a date where a lady I've
split the bill before in my life it's
just not the way what did that one girl
say
um you can't afford me oh God
I run like I literally wrong safe let me
know like I really literally just run
away from those kind of women there is a
tick tock I saw it where it was like the
girl and the guy it was like two ups
workers and the girl was like you can't
afford me and he's like we have the same
job
yeah it's funny but no no it's always
the way they try to make you feel less
than a man because of of whatever you
can't take them to buy them whatever
fancy you can go like you know take him
to a proper nightclub or something like
that and I walked in in like nightlife
for like 10 years and I saw this sort of
this sort of facade if a girl is really
about money then she can be easily
bought that's my opinion okay can be
easily bought by a next person so if he
even spending a couple dropping a couple
of bags on her it just all it takes is a
note is a bigger man to come and you
take her so she would never use it was
just your turn
what the men under swim like what would
you define as a a bad spending habit in
your opinion uh someone who doesn't have
you have priorities do you see what I'm
saying is my rent paid is my bills paid
is everything that I need to
carry on this month sort it out before I
go off and buy lavish uh nights out with
my girls or uh shoes or clothes or do
you know what I mean yes but having your
priorities in order first
yeah opposed to having it the other way
around so let's just say those
priorities are in order for a particular
woman but she still expects certain
things from you
are you now what are these certain
things you have to specify I don't know
like just to say she wants to go out to
a certain restaurant and she expects you
to pay for that okay well what has what
has she done in the relationship to say
that I so it requires her to be a
certain status in the relationship
absolutely so you're down for it it just
depends on well if if for example I only
see you on the weekends and you bring
nothing really to my life except for you
getting done up and wanting to go out to
fancy restaurants that's a no you know
if you're somebody who who if you know
what I'm doing and you know what I'm
about because you spend that sort of
time with me and I tell you about my
business and you go oh you know what I
might know somebody or how can I help or
whatever whatever you deserve those
nights not just how I got my [ __ ] done
girl I'm gonna take him you're gonna
make him take me out I said no
I hate what you're saying
um my brothers
um they like won't date girls if they
feel like their lifestyle is too
expensive my brothers they all make six
figures and they can they can afford
like they could afford a lot for a woman
but like if a girl comes in expecting of
them to pay for all their [ __ ] and like
I don't know they just won't they it's
just too much of a headache I can't
afford you yeah
potential holes in this in your in your
boat if you're a man yeah and the Sheep
represents you because those are hoes
because what you think what you have to
look at is in long term about how that
woman is exactly you know how like if
she's like that and she's moved
especially through social media yeah
this is really like you know socially
conditioned to move by what's going on
in social media she's gonna put holes in
your [ __ ] or imagine
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible